до питання до зони конфлікту
доброго через ви здавалося що вина за
кенджі тикових станеш моток український
землі буду з вільно але ви мало на уазі
крим такими муками
відомо про балки поверніть то але
ситуація з кримом з чистої води аншлюс
з анексія суверенної української
території цифру б порушення
міжнародного права інтерншнл про тих
кому жувала кухаря і ніжний вдало так
така ціна ви правда не у нас багато
прикладі працював купати її пивну
території вимагав і d4 ніж млрд через
міжнародні права то порядок мати but
і видно в ній трохи переставав а лазівки
cups to win Росія поверне і в австрії
gracia щоб пам'ять
агресор має бути підкорений алое і це
дуже важливо деталь ми по-моєму
спрацювати вимкнено дипломатичним
шляхів інструменти поруч і по столу
складне завданням чоловік тексті вже ківі
стандарти в Україні будуть вищими нижче
криму та
та standard of living out by мати я хочу
свобода слова преса та соколиних свобод
і буду більше людей
я решті у європейської нації ще
мій безвізовий режим із чим дає свободу
бізнесу щось із чорного бізнесу
тоді люди в криму захоче статою
українцям і на президента добре
справа чого любить ти вичавлюєш conti
криму
інша навесні реальний sweet ви не можете
забрати крим силу митя russian і вам його
на вигляд дадуть для путіна c було
призначено самгупс тв
ви знаєте я знаю та rush the sweet
успішна шини будуть красивішими сказати про
працю людям
я зовсім не хочу з друкувати з вами тим
i'm always with розумі є у c
незаконної анексії legal an excess
weight with 170 державні ви знаєте
анексію щось обіцяють не кулагіна
визнавати
з нього-то колажі ван і прийняв її china
так чому вії не він і не визнала
прийняв і
але ніхто в Європейському союзі не викликати
його на моїй польоті fda криму на мої
ділових до дипломатичних вид носом з
кримом не консульств мечева
0 інвестиції до крима з паза та ціни ви
знання від неї і прийняти акт and even нод
і нок і як бійці такого ніхто в ви б
що легше ми змиримося і визнаємо am c
буду з упором дорученням тару його не
можу хвору на систему bespeco
і буде стимулом для агресора і від
футбик, буду абсолютно ти сам ще й
1938 уроку
я просто він не може собі в ев то з
тих хто не будь то в уроку, ви розумієте
ще австрія завжди буду німецьку йому я
адже ти була не я розумію алеппо не
президент подивитись на окупацію
західного берега річки Йордан
ізраїлем, що відриває 50 роки у дружини
наш чоловічок і постачаєте окупацію
законну aleksey прийняв вулицею факт з
кримом буду це саме сказати про берег,
від камію не там ще за нами правда і
височі светр з ви можете сказати це
самий європа лист intel
днів ми ви зовсім вищі за ситуацію і
агресор повністю ізольовані малюк
реальність тому що
зупинені для вас рамка дня в тому
чехова не хоче вид вас для вас не буду
я повноцінного членства в ес
повноцінного членства в тому, що
європейці миколи в бочці тема не буду
there'sa когось процес роботи приголомшений
і russian і в той же час заплатив і високу ціну
за грубі порушення
висока ціна за санкцією ситуація в
економіці стан золотовалютних
резервів
я високо цінувалася філч прайс subs йдіть
адже за кримів не здайся надавати і
вічного пласт право
будемо реалістами відомо росія можуть
не держава олексій свято заморити з
агресією except
також ніколи ні акули з ним там
врахує сем стане символом того що
глобальна система bespeco створена
після друга і світлове провини не проти
з на треку ви поважаєте що україна cool
і небудь визнаєте доната так така
нервова майбутньому мої будні на алані
матчу на заявив Джон ебашить вас пішла
нам на те містер за культурні права fair
and франк-вальтер штайнмайєр заявив рик
тому виступати і я бачу україни від
партнера на вірну то ми шануємо і мої мій
віпа виду тим критерієм альянсу всього
треба секти сьогодні я б завтра такого
вам видно вали на дату типу днів у 2008
роті на цьому що ж Росія загортала
і ваші праху не пісні шиташ теми на
саміті над та 2008 уроку у бухаресті все
буланів поки їм очі я у всі двері для
грузії то україни шинка не бат align
нічого натру смуги там ще україни на
вигляд побачила криті ренату
там уже росія сказав вони не давиться
Росія сказала не це дісней
прем'єр-міністр Франції за його you ми
проти ступу грузії то україни тому що
ми поважаємо їжте ціни крадіжок тобі перемогти
на проблему балансу сил у Європі цифри
бризнуть міста ясна то все вашу думку і
думку французького президента прем'єра
прем'єром ви майже
червоною все видав ось і ми не ви слова ти
свою думку там і суверенна вона закладена
Держава ми не живимо в дозу ну не в
росії небудь cowin живу
наша позиція необхідно реформувати
свою україну 1 сек вона потребує вощеної
менше 6 7 рокки is the medic девід
побачити і критерієм альянсу
реформи з ви не іншу роботу і до
потрібно нам і вище шляху ми моєму,
українці чохол, що організував референдум
ледве громадина українці вступили в нато
через це rocky
стоїть і не з'їсть такого мс-1 вимагаємо від
запитаної
так тут моєму дві сторони лайки
низинними тбілісі протистояння двох
рокки
ви сир цьому рівні 3 з колишніми знати
це членство в альянсі 102 16500 ким
населення сьогодні 60 відсотків петрі
мульти відео
spot of basic steps
я розумію що ви хочете цього шукає його
прогнати українці алла ви живете я кажу
про стала не заходу даватися захисника
лайнапе динари за консультацією такого
роду в Росії ви живете посилити її
сьогоднішнього дня чи вечора пальці
захисті ми висимо років світло буде зовсім
і нашим і натомість сьогодні їжі на
ефективна система без пекін тому що
все ще системи бесп
і струйного не російської окупації це
агресію сюди україни серії там ще
далі краєм ситуацій і не довести
своїм партнерам що світло стане
безтурботними що україна від риму можна
везти зрубати і c11 я марк вінка світла
в кінці тунелю б матового ти нас
проводите реформи у тримати вони не ціні
позиція не мучениці позиція штайнмайєра
у 2015 у Росії ніхто не знаючи який
буде позиції мечами 2020 другові здається
що це чому конфлікт за європу чинити
операх росії, а ви не роз'їдало такому
жив і весь що європе русі потрібно
більше не живу вона була потрібна колаж
лося про 1 резерву то його ядерну
програму вона потребує досягнення
компромісу 4 цій боротьбі за ісламську
державу ви пропан це європе продати
інтересу україни я нічого не пропаду я
ті колеса через задали б такому жили
адже що європейцями мішина,
між будуть і вам crazy не кажуть кістки
pequod
слідом загар на харчування і за рахунок так і
Європейський Союз
ось юнайтед все бідну 26 держав у гаю
ринок росія bespeco security
не ціною випадок таки раб даллес ельбан і
чому і абсолютно пвн шкідливостей з і
солідарність з україною соледарі ти всю
кров ми всі цінне харчування top gear
, Тіно стоїть запущена в ліс yandex потрібно
таким самим і єдиним виглядаєш сьогодні
європейський союз не має ні випробування
біженців не випробувань агресія не
випробування україна
all i were here is приводу україни з
наведу греції
їжу жах подівся з приводу проблеми
біженців в Європу образливе з початку
2014 року я зустрічався з б особистістю
міністрів за кордон із профліста
заплутував я все буду агресія ніж у
злого що євросоюз
заощаджень стазу проводити santee та
знає річку і було відповіді
не консенсусу з приводу голосування the
sunshine я буду ніколи а я сказав буди та
через три місяці так ядра балуйся будь
ласка вдома не будемо він цього синього
то європейський союз з and land on дст
терапії new не підставляй muse початку
нами гідом у владі столітті здаються досить
кришкою ми ж крима проти моста не гнів
якщо гель кох місяців за 1000
ми знову побачила від броні zip мені якось
артилерійські обстріли обидва з я
придумала проти місяця скупо рушницю не
режиму перемир'я чепрак в'язниці ці
перепони його в не порушення буде нашою
частини шоти митьки та мовляв на стіни
простягнути правда палець slade у лакінську
z не послухають у нас, а душа серйозна
диспут я домагайся каже ей ви просто
вивчи союзнику менти це затемнення все
означають і мінської домовленості з
просто план мирного врегулювання ніхто
не може буде і проти них там ще вдома
влада пропонує причини не в гнізді
кури станемо ваших ви дива зброї звивин
або за ручники без посередник доступу з
після дачі в дугу дику територію до
збривають брови не гуманітарні
організації по ви не від риму ти можна
весь допомогти врегулюванню монетарну
щури моя виду вата
соціально-економічну троянди качок
території аполітична частини нате ієгуда
назвеш ні, а справедливі вибори
дозволити людям у луганську та донецьку
апарати з них представляє канськ олег
directed to call та ви пропустили украй
рядків не
аджабун встановлений дедлайн і про те
вибори пронесли доступний рік з вашого
до валу ціни я-то їх щось пропускає
дедлайн там вивчати україна вигляд поведана
державам та віту видаль на учасники
Мінську будинків вона стоїть але робомів тисячу
житла а тут мінську гримлять
така чомусь діви duty ракетні
обстріли на сході України і хоча я їх не
пам'ятаю ну і сьогодні виступати я
святу заповідь про б з'їв 20 давно на
сайті Павло Розенко з картинка питання
її мало не так вони вже були думав і
process takes it all up не там шукаю наше
позиція абсолютно відразу мило ми
повністю готовий вести проти isabel
знімаємо ми відкрити і до проведення всіх
інспекції алла чомусь дивани за видами
ляє проти ваших радість знаходиться там
дані по ви не заходять і якими ви бачок
чудо злотих
у нас є новий список до перемоги я адже
повідана заявляю що ми повністю ви
канали в сізо б в'язання в рамках
мінських ось
включено світло введенням у школу з брови
не означає все додати у psn і точно
бачила у нас на мою ж ногу пункту я
ковбой навик у нали implements
до мінська і час то диван і з'являються
тима будь ласка алан йому жити but i
правим і 1 приватні bc і ви офігенні
ванни
тема була пекельна чого ви гідні не
одну хлинів
якою ми ж побачили учасники мінських
у рік їх що ми бачимо це кільки
до перемоги в безоплаті та українській
сторони то російську сторони
хто росія у 2015 розділ частки
порушила перемир'я, починаючи обстріли
куди росіян вона дала доступ і
міжнародним врятував передачам ягоду
кордону так і на території без знаходите
вас брови і все у нас буде n і випаду
голими михайлів порада вілли через сорок
wuling якщо візу і toothpaste лігачів
інспектор він і зафіксував із бронею
п'ятсот метрів за двадцять три
кілометрів та лінії фронту hands-free
кілометрів врятував тригодинні вали і ми ні
хрону прибрав його до [ __ ] wave охорони про
секвестр вибач йому зуби з'їв на тисячах
ми не допускала їх доз броні та тембер
шаман із прямого йому з броні протез
пасторі гачів за голом у вас різанини
інтерпретації того, щоб справджуються не
ситуація ми повністю в ікону йому мінську
будинків лінощами ланцюга створіння джон л б с е 2
немає емоцій було так чому ти назвав
дискусії ціни передача я відразу після
інтерв'ю я дам вам цифри для ваших завдань
і там вчитися на безтурботно rich сценарій
російської сторони
указу ти що б дві сторони доручив і
думав даністю впала не мінську від ціни
так українці повністю всі канали
графства варту це диво не доведено
поверни дозвольте повернути-то сюди далеких
ваших вбити а ну які виклик був і
став президентом
1 знак було боротися з корупцією
буквально місяць тому пішла США в Україні
винні в генпрокуратуру повинен і
звучне включення про протез брати без
корупцію то порошку джанні роботі
владних спершу битних його ніж у ван
прокурор даси позики і свою посаду легше
Віндіс нарубайте чому його заново чого так
що ви серйозно ти на світ боротися
зі скрутіть її в чому ви дозволяєте з
ситуації так розвиватися абат до
черевикам про себе на висоті ще такого
танці зі статуї фунту сфінкс фасції і не
вір
авто я пошту з двох моментів перше без
посередника якщо розмова ми полагодимо
розслідуванням незалежного розслідування
встиг пройти з нашими американськими
партнерами я сподівайся все за дикін
не за лижним розслідуванням в офісі
генерального прокурора було 3 травня майки
з фактами корупції ці факти підтвердяться
то зручну їхню волину тільки викликаного
кит і заново не проти купити поверніть
мені запишіть на свої посади
інший момент ми хочемо з творить і
ефективна система боротьби з корупцією
містер чи в антикорупційне бюро
етику ризикуєте вона і віднімемо ременем
довіра з абсолютно protherm процесом
при значенні нових корінних iv-го але
розпущена робота першого на кшталт алла
два дні тому дав і хотів з України по
вид малюка в торгово над інктобера
вчительства поранити його
антикорупційного бюро
а пацани типу dying ангес не
. нагадала вам щось допомагай з на даєте
за розумом та доповіді груп україни точно не
доступна рік дня адже ми сторони на
людину з конкурсної комісії щось увімкнула
та й з кладуть їх когось пропливав
євросоюз включає містера теслера річки
представлятиме євросоюз зверху ось і
президентом піньйон я одягайся
рада проголосую зони хто у нас реакція
дуже швидко щось ефективно ленной
очолиш і запустити нову
антикорупційну структуру без
середньої після 1 грудня
на очолиш і рахунок їй довіряв і
український народ, а органи влади
європейський то американські партнери
премії сваріться
а в Європі та америці замість про поні
президент ви хоче і показати що
пуччиною tiu.ru
ви хочете продемонструвати відкритості
ганьбити новачок президенту владно
телебачення
5 канал зайчика і хоч активно критикує
новачок шоу повного дружина vbs випробуваний
свободи змії
з
зал h top on порушений куповий нам про
дати світлий канал
тему та твердо упевнень віддала wanna
що лайки політики непу ви не володіти ти
та контролю вати мас-медіа України є
це вже чутно за харчуванням 2003 року ляльки та
був про позитивне поле таке я створи в
мовляв вільною вами в Україні віків були
абсолютно прозу revit але сцени не
журналістам про його знайомство з памперси
приклад mg cost of example
paul c конфлікт інтересів чини так нитки
ми пробач ти чи можеш його
а чи ви убити али і дражнять всі види
вухах bad i promise the beautiful
не я nicula але убити себе продати та
п'ятий канал поки
be цілих і дражнять якщо виду
олігархи крики володіти масмедіа
on different та fierce я модифікуються
легше ви подавитеся і п'ятий канал тайвін
можна його
беляши за все критикуючи вин на та пак
винний сліду ж авторитетніший за журналістів
, був journalist
вальс алла для чого він вам ваш
президент у вас і злидні роботи для чого
послухати ctos президенті в Європі мої
владний телеканал нтв freedom високої
ти
я гарант свободи преси в Україні та
стандарти журналісти кенобі адама каналі
ніхто не критий до і
відкритий секс м фа дід здавався вас що я
шоколадний бізнес у Росії
такі ви обіцяли про дати але так
теплий зір була своя вбити а
і чим можна ви канал і там участь на
мого бізнесу в Росії було конфісковано
путін і частково на бізнесі заарештовано
неможливо про дати заснований бізнес
чому б ви іфтара т-ти графині там ще
активи заарештовано
алаш ви могли порадіти харчування в
руки трастів відгуки та тигони забула
не ми вже підписали трасту на догоду
зубним і знаю найавторитетніших
європейських трас і передали активи
абсолютно на закладеному менеджменті
спасибі за допомогою кову я їх навчаю ви
розв'яжіть проблему аллофс уного за вишилася
від тіла на з як ти вілл і києвом
накласти цих ви обіцяли по збуту si te
ми вам чоловіки подібно до мого вигляду алія
єдині український президент та києві
відкрито передавши свої активи дон і
залежних від трастового фонду з гену
репутацію я думаю що це по-європейськи
cool та краї на уста не провини і ніхто не
хоче у когось бізнес
розділи ти бізнес то політику separate
бізнес і керувався ви також вбити Алли
видом у цій собі практика та гаманців
їх армій мало так дзвони добровольці
батальйони за крим від правого сектора
даси і служити їм шукав олігархи
а ви кажемо їх, що олігархи українці не
буду так вже досьє снують він визволив і
свої активи those who've плив і яким
його на шкури сталося на місяців їх
виборах затока рейлінг ви повинні провину
інтерпретують і мої та білянки я на
убити огляд у нього ти правий сектор з
політична партія ata промінструмент
muvit
alicia армія і по ній можна ми не
завершили свій вигляд від вічка
a promise я обіцяю розбрід та їхній вигляд
виставити лінії фронту
розумієш 1 представлений до правого
сектора на передавити пліз
c-dur і чіпом скидання поліції вона
президента тут із санкт ними
illegal червоний я даю в козявки rus бро його
ти і будете на закон news броні
формуванням не заражаються на такому
ванни на лежати олігарху ніж не закон про
збрую не політичний групі об'єктів
бос і легше ви будуть об'єктивними
the liar хижий армії розкид не всі
ще одна армія правого сектора of right
sector правий сектор знаходиться у
процесі розкидання не ціна просто і
завдання в собі в Україні ще стрибуна я
натискаю на перестрілку ніжним це
поліції на голоку вид за фінку кордонів
все було та й галькою місяців тому обидва
сцену куди вже броні знайти той же
тут на другій кампанії за ставками і не
я з пробую на ньому і повис ти б не
став так вул і стала одразу милість у тебе
був конфлікт mesh правом сектором то
поліцію
то було дроту новачка по рації з
розкид не правого сектора 1 сектор і
світі книгою на кіл і правий сектор
намахався з права kuwait та бийте у
національної гвардії ми провалилися кову
апараті в
прищ я домагайся знову вам навесні-то
я президент країни чиє перебування вуста
не провини у нас маса оружня і ми нам
обжита ефективний заході в
розкидай не запас почитай закон то
порядок і добрим свічки ним ті ходить а
що всі війська на українському боті до 3
травня режиму пунктуації вогнем
викладають накази головнокомандування
збруйник сил україни and [ __ ] a life
ну і творці довіряю більше не збоку
правозахисних організацій у порушені
проблеми вікна вашому боті так і на боті
вашого супротивника чубу для
розслідування staff of papers немає там
ще пару шень з нашого булку мають
абсолютно
sobre штаб всі доручення з української
боку bull і
розслідування на нижніх чинах за
злочинності міжнародних інспекторів
ось того боку ними все море сниться
is not and reference та ми цивілізоване
європейське за іржава до виконна своє
вбити anki
а он і бандити і терористи їх ще я
закину остуди
ви зможете перуку над і систему на
влада нього та масть international здається
щоб дві сторони би спиць то всередині ми
були цивільні осі пекін з койли жадібних
звучання а потім показував і ставок або ж
не стане легше випади в офісі на
статистику того я до багатий випромінювання в
української армії буду розслідуванням
Якоба готові на них притихли Давид Паві
дальності то з року відповідь amnesty
international sa об'єктивно
каспій об'єктів
1 година 1 реакціями було збоку банди
терористів
у б там висимо тисяч українців і жадібно
вид паве дальність це сторона не
понесла або responsibility for the site
понад дві тисячі українських солдат
вбитих російськими солдатами і 1 по
дальності зачіп за темряви
давайте не будемо огорож і на безпечніше
брюс дні гри мовляв про б дві сторони на
суді побачилися не цілісні ми, а росія
на нападають на нас ціни і ми
а от і виявляють у нас агресію, щоб ти
буває кидає і заново чого не пружині
про стравами воно б ми на вигляд кидаємо а ми
розслідуємо
ми не замикай чому я просто хочу сказати
вам що ми inci
міс піп росію ми з міжнародними
організаціями human rights and
international ми відкриття до проведення
розслідування листи про в'язницю з і
хороший при кладці європейський символ
crying i'm був гаррі good summer open
вона пряжинку дякую за те, що прийшли до
нас зону конфлікту дякую